now I have the great honor of
introducing Meryl Streep
I loved her performance in the ours it
really made me think and for that I will
never forgive her here's one of
America's finest actresses Meryl Streep
someone wasn't said the more praise a
man is willing to take the less he
probably deserves whoever said that must
have been insane oh there's no it
whoever said that must have been had the
ever reluctant and as such deeply
deserving recipient of tonight's
honorary Oscar award in mind Peter
O'Toole was nominated for the Oscar
he was nominated for the Oscar for Best
Actor a lucky seven times and like many
of our best was overlooked on every
every occasion he was overlooked but far
from unnoticed bursting on the screen on
a screen that could barely contain him
he played the title role in David Lean's
magnificent Lawrence of Arabia with
with fierce grace and extraordinary ease
Noel Coward remarked on this
accomplishment if you had been any
prettier it would have been florence of
arabia classically-trained he returned
to the stage again and again he played
50 roles in four years at the Old Vic
alone and he was one of the great
Hamlet's he was also well cast as Kings
in a dazzling array of film performances
after praying playing Henry the second
and Becket opposite his friend Richard
Burton he reprised the role opposite
Katharine Hepburn in the line in winter
even real Kings don't get a second
chance like that he's had a strong run
of gentlemen with titles and delusional
dreamers in such films as Man of La
Mancha and Caligula man Friday and Lord
Jim's fan galley and the last emperor in
the ruling class he plays a man who
thinks he's God in the stuntman he plays
a man who doesn't think he's God he
knows he's God in other words a film
director and in the hilarious and
touching my favorite year he sums it all
up in a rollicking performance as a
great swashbuckling movie actor who's
terrified of acting he even gets to
deliver the actor's mantra dying is easy
comedy is hard and with a golden voice
that lifts Guild's and animates ordinary
words and the light in his eyes if he'd
swallowed the pale blue moon Peter
O'Toole's gift has beguiled us for 40
years
ladies and gentlemen Peter O'Toole
Meryl Streep members of the Academy
distinguished guests viewers ladies and
gentlemen always a bridesmaid never a
bride my foot
I have my very own Oscar now to be with
me to death us do part
I wish the Academy to know that I was
delighted as I am honored and I am
honored the magic of the movies
enraptured me when I was a child as I
taught her into antiquity movie magic in
raptures mr. having already bagged this
baby as it were and so spared
uncertainties prior to the opening of an
envelope I'm able to think
I think of our colleagues our old
friends now gone who played their parts
in this ceremony I think of the
sumptuous talent alive and well and with
us now I think of the astonishing young
the gifted enable young men and women
who I meet practically every time I go
to work and from whom I grab energy in
handfuls I think of the United States
and all the loves and friendships I've
known here for more than half a century
and of how much the nation has given to
me both personally privately and
professionally I'm deeply thankful and
now at this last you give me this
delightful shock your very good good
night and God bless you
you